so a cube has perfect symmetry right you
know what I mean every face is the same
and tetrahedron has perfect symmetry
okay there are four faces and they're
all the same
you can ask and Euclid did what are all
of the symmetric three-dimensional
objects and it turns out there are only
five of them most people know what a
cube is in a tetrahedron but there are
also an octahedron which has eight faces
you know four on top and four on the
bottom and it's again perfectly
symmetrical every way you twist and turn
it it looks the same just like a cube
and then there are two others there's
the icosahedron and the dodecahedron
that's it so first you might think well
if there are so many funny ones why
aren't there lots of different ones so I
proved that in class I mean it's a
surreal theorem and I said therefore
there only five fair dice because each
of those dice would be fair that is if I
wanted to generate a number between one
and eight I rolled the octahedron each
of these faces is equally likely to come
out somehow intuitively we know that you
know that's a fair dice which has eight
sides and the kid raises his hand in
class and said I have a thirty sided die
and I said no you don't and he said I do
when you first meet it it's just some
lumpy roundish thing but in fact it's
called a rhombic try Kanta hydron and it
has 30 faces and all of the faces are
the same size they're all little
rhombuses that's why it's called a
rhombic thing now this die isn't as
symmetric as the other ones this vertex
has five faces that meet at this vertex
but this vertex has three faces that
meet at this vertex so it's not as
symmetrical for example the cube has
three faces at each vertex
you know when every edge has two sides
and so there's a question is it fair and
what does that mean well of course we
know what it means in practice we mean
if we throw it you know it should land
on each of the 30 faces 30th of the time
but let me talk about that for a second
when I was a graduate student we had a
guy who was a retired executive who
wanted to test the laws of chance and he
came into the department and he said I
like throwing dice when I watch
television and actually Brady might be
that some of your viewers might want to
participate in this and in the end he
wound up rolling a die three and a half
million times and recording
how many times did each face come out
and here are some things you learn the
first thing is that die so if you roll
them a lot get round of course they do
if you roll a die 20,000 times it you
know bounces around the changes so we
had to give him new dice that notion of
long-term frequency it's actually pretty
fictional the second thing was dice the
way they're made the dice he was using
have pips drilled in them and filled
with ain't so there's a six has six
spots in it well those drill holes are
lighter so the six face actually has
less mass in the one face which is
opposite has more you know they weren't
fair now casino dice are much more
carefully made the holes are filled with
paint of the same specific gravity as
the surrounding material so they really
are pretty close to fair when you start
thinking about anything even something
as silly as as what does it mean to say
a dice die is fair there are things to
think about of course okay so I wanted
to think about what does it mean to say
this die is fair there's the notion of
the symmetry group of a dice a symmetry
of an object any object is a set of all
transformations I can make like turning
it a quarter or turning it this way
or turning it over which bring it atom
for atom where it was okay so that's
called the symmetry group and of course
if I have one symmetry like turning at a
quarter turn I can do it twice I can go
once twice right so I can combine the
symmetry of flip that way with the
symmetry of a flip that way so we say
the the symmetries of an object form a
group all that means is you can take one
symmetry and then take another symmetry
and compose them do them twice you have
to be able to undo it so if I just did
this I can undo it
what's it was a function you could
perform on a dice for example that you
couldn't undo just by doing it backwards
suppose that the die was made out of
jell-o and I flattened it I couldn't
undo that probably that
be a symmetry okay that is the
definition right right exactly exactly
takes it Adam for Adam to where it is
and and you know of course you can
reverse it different objects have
different notions of symmetry so this
tetrahedron it has less symmetry somehow
the number of different things I can do
to it it's less than what I can do to
this there are twelve symmetries that I
can make of this if you start fiddling
and there 24 symmetries that I can make
with this die and obviously some giant
thing like this you know there are a lot
of different things I could do to it Joe
Keller and I defined an object to be
fair by symmetry if it's group of
transformations was transitive on the
faces and all that means is I can take
the die and leave it Adam for Adam the
same but have any face where this faces
you know right now the two is up in the
rhombus well I should be able to make
the ten come up by a symmetry and have
the die just exactly where it was but
have the ten up we define the die to be
fair by symmetry if it's symmetries act
transitively on the faces meaning I can
take any face to any other face this die
its symmetry group isn't transitive on
the vertices I can't take this vertex
which has five things around it into
this vertex which has three things
around it I could move this vertex to
there but the surrounding territory will
be different we did prove that this die
has a transitive symmetry group not by
vertex but yes but yes by face and not
by edges either actually so we did show
that this die has a transitive symmetry
group that's fair so it's fair
it sounds fair now if every face is the
same and since the Betts are going to be
on the faces it sounds fair then we had
the idea what are all affair dice Euclid
found the completely fair dice that is
Euclid's theorem is what are all the
objects whose groups are transitive on
their faces on their edges and on their
vertices and the cube of course you can
see every vertex looks the same right
and similarly every edge looks the same
not
this guy and with Joe we classified all
of the fair dice suppose I had a five
gone and then let's put a point up here
and down here and connect that point
fill in the solid so it's got five edges
and then it'll have five triangles going
up and five triangles going down that's
a fair object because these five
triangles all are the same and they're
obviously the same as these five
triangles and so every triangle is the
same but I could put that point wherever
I want and you'd get very different
looking dice right you'd get a kind of
little tiny thing or a very long thing
but so that's a one parameter family of
ten sided dice what we found is that
there are thirty families of fair dice
we classified them and then we found out
that Archimedes had been there before us
about twenty-five hundred years ago how
many members does each family have or is
it an infinite infinite because there's
a continuous parameter but it's
interesting that there were you know two
continuous parameters we have a list
some of the things on the list don't
have a parameter in them some of them do
we found all the possible fair dice you
told me you could do that with a
Pentagon and I follow that made sense
right I could imagine you could do that
with a hexagon and a $7 night what can
you do it without to hundreds it's true
now it's true what you say and you've
caught me Brady because that exactly
that's exactly correct so why isn't that
infinitely many infinitely many fair
dice it is and so let me amend the
statement of my theorem that's an
infinite family that is an infinite
family and it has what we call dihedral
symmetry that is the only symmetry that
those dice have is these sides are all
the same and these sides are all the
same and these sides are all the same as
these sites okay so guys with more than
dihedral symmetry that is we call them
interesting dice they have extra
symmetry so the example I just gave is
trivial to use well it's important
example if I took this tetrahedron and
if I had another one and I stuck them
together that would be a triangle a
point above and a point below right so
here it is I made
and obviously you know this is a
six-sided thing here here are three
sides here are the other three sides
these three are all the same these three
are all the same so this is a fair thing
now if you flipped it of course you'd
have to roll it and you'd have to talk
about the side that lands down here's
another six-sided die is there any sense
in which we can say that this die is
more or less fair than this die it's a
philosophical question it's a math
question the symmetry group of this die
there are just six symmetries you can
twist it around three things or you
could turn it over and twist it around
three things the size of the symmetry
group is as small as it could be whereas
this die has twenty-four symmetries what
does that mean I know I once did a
number file video about flipping a coin
so I got a friend with a stopwatch and I
went one two three flip one two three
flood and when we were talking about
that we said well of course physics
should come into this description of
fairness someplace of course it should
come in with dice and it's the same
physics it's mechanic's
if I roll the die very carefully so it
just goes around these four faces on a
blanket well that's not very fair
because these faces could not come up
when you release the dye from your hand
if you're actually rolling it it has
velocity and it has angular velocities
and there's a phase space what direction
is it going in and how fast and then how
fast is it turning in each of various
directions and they're actually twelve
dimensions of parameters needed to
describe the initial conditions what we
can show is that that twelve dimensional
space of initial conditions is
partitioned up into six regions regions
where if the die leaves your hand when
the initial positions are in this part
of the phase space it comes up aside one
all of the initial conditions where the
die comes up at side two it can only
come up in one of six faces so that
partitions the this twelve dimensional
space into region six different regions
the partitioning up of face space is
much finer for this die then for this
tile this partitioning is cruder for any
way of rolling small changes in the
initial conditions the difference
between your hand and your brain make
for a big difference in what side it
comes up because the partitioning of the
face base is finer so there is a sense
in which symmetry isn't the only
determining factors expand symmetry
combine to allow a reasonably
satisfactory analysis of just how fair
dice or so the cube is fair
the cube is fairer tiny little changes
in just how you release it will make for
the difference between side 1 and side 2
whereas the basins of attraction for
side you know 1 up to 6 with this two
tetrahedral die or cruder and so it
would be easier to control for example
you know a coin is the simplest kind of
dice the simplest kind of diet just has
two cases right obviously heads and
tails are symmetric but of course when
you really flip a coin you know the
flips matter and I once had a colleague
who was at a junior high school and he
called up and said I gave my kids the
problem of flipping a coin and when they
flipped coins it was very very patterned
you know head tail head tail head tail
head tail and he couldn't understand it
and I went in and watched the kids flip
and they were bored out of their minds
and they were just doing wimpy little
flips you know so that it would flip
once now of course it's going to come up
head tail head tail so you know how you
flip can make a difference how you roll
a die can make a difference this isn't
the end in fact our next video will be
the second part of this interview with
Professor diaconis talking more about
fair dice and casino dice if you can't
wait until then there are links on the
screen and in the video description you
can watch it right now you're talking to
me about dice and fairness is like
talking to a California wine person
about wine it can go on forever right so
let me go back
and as some of you know there are plenty
more dice videos on numberphile you can
look at our back catalogue and look at
this one it's coming very soon from
Tadashi
four four four four and zero zero that's
something to get excited about links on
the screen and in the video description
thank you so much everyone for watching
our videos we really appreciate it